Vladimir Putin's Russia poses the
greatest current threat to Nato those
are the words of German Chancellor Olaf
Schultz in a keynote speech delivered a
short time ago to Germany's armed forces
the bundesphere Schultz told German
military leaders that they should accept
that Russia will Define itself as an
adversary to the European Union the U.S
and NATO for the foreseeable future and
he said Germany's Armed Forces must
become the best equipped military force
in Europe
Deutschland is Germany is ready to take
on leadership responsibility for the
security of our continent continents
that's the most populous nation in
Europe with the largest economy and as a
country in the middle of the continent
our army must become a Cornerstone of
conventional defense in Europe
and become the best equipped military
force that is the goal and we should be
motivated by the knowledge that our
European partners and friends do not
perceive this goal as a threat but as
reassurance
DW's Chief political correspondent
Melinda crane followed the Chancellor's
speech and I asked her earlier if the
German military is really ready to take
on a leading role in Europe's security
certainly the military is still very
under equipped the chancellor himself
acknowledged major gaps and deficits in
military Readiness and said that in fact
the bundes fair is working on multiple
fronts at the moment to try to close
those gaps not least with increasing
budgetary support but as we heard there
he did make it clear that he sees this
as an absolutely top priority that
Germany equipped the bundesphere in such
a way that it can become a foundational
pillar of European security and he
mentioned Germany's friends and allies
in that that remark that we just heard
in fact many friends and allies found
themselves asking in February after the
chancellor gave his historic Turning
Point speech whether this represents the
moment when Germany finally starts
punching at its weight and actually
assuming a security and defense role
commensurate with its economic role in
Europe and clearly the chancellor was
saying here we are ready to do that he
said sometimes he's heard people ask
well this new 100 billion special fund
to equip the bundes fair does that mean
it's going to be business as usual but
with a little more money and he said no
it's not we have a different set of
priorities going forward now certainly
those will that will be music to the
ears of those who are looking for
Germany to take on more leadership in
that division of responsibility within
NATO but many will still be waiting to
see whether this government is ready to
walk the talk absolutely and what else
did the chancellor say in his speech
well many people who were waiting to see
whether he would mention additional
weapons deliveries and Military Support
for Ukraine will have been disappointed
that was not on his agenda but in fact
the defense minister had said yesterday
that Germany will now be supplying
multiple missile launchers and also uh
and also armored vehicles to Ukraine not
however the battle tanks that Ukraine
itself has been pushing for and beyond
that there was a very clear
acknowledgment from Chancellor Schultz
that when the government looks to the
risks that Germany and Europe face as
you mentioned earlier Russia is
absolutely at the top of the threat list
but that these threats are not simply
conventional military and defense
threats but very much also cyber
security threats energy security threats
that demand an all of government
approach really far are beyond the
military alone and that also demand much
stronger coordination with allies DW's
Melinda crane thanks so much for that
and now to some of the other stories
making news around the world
Berlin has put the German subsidiary of
Russian oil giant rosnaft under
trusteeship now that means a federal
regulator will take control of a large
refinery in the Eastern German Town of
schweet which used to draw 100 of its
oil from Russia Germany has committed to
ending all Russian oil imports and is
looking for alternative sources to keep
the refinery running
and the Russian President Vladimir Putin
has hailed the growing influence of what
he called new centers of power at a
summit with Asian leaders including
China's Xi Jinping in Uzbekistan he's
Keen to show Russia has not been fully
isolated by the conflict in Ukraine
Putin also denounced the use of
sanctions by Western Nations over his
invasion